tighten them out with the rest of the
garbage
let the wasteland deal with them
get out of my city
[Music]
what
i'm not allowed to have a bad dream
[Applause]
no wastelander
has ever made it to the reckoning before
[Applause]
but here i am
a free-for-all
with zero rules
[Applause]
and the survivor
gets the throne
[Applause]
king howell
has never lost
not in 13 years of rule on the
battlefield
not until
today
did you really think this would be a
fair
fight you don't survive the reckoning
unless the winner
grabs your mercy
that's why i've got to win this whole
all right
let's get this started
[Music]
[Music]
scavengers like you ain't so bad
[Music]
you know how to fight dirty
[Music]
come on big boy
what are you smiling about if you're
smart enough to run the tinkers why are
you working for this stronger
not you'd be any better
[Music]
at least i won't shoot my friends in the
back
[Music]
you haven't had a real fight
in 13 years
we had them
everybody died
not in this arena
[Music]
oh
this meathead has a bigger magnet
geiger
[Applause]
that could have gone better
[Music]
[Music]
you idiot i'll kill you for that
no
not today
[Music]
[Music]
oh
mercy
i'll give you
the same mercy you showed my family 13
years ago
get out of my city
[Music]
[Music]
well
that turned out all right didn't it but
now they're probably wondering what sort
of changes i'll make around here
well buckler
they're about to find out
this is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you